i am right here
at the burger cathedral i'm going to
live it i got an email that said that
i'm going to be on it i record it of
course my heart's feeding 6 000 miles an
hour
[Music]
my name is george moats and it's my job
to protect the american hamburger it's a
hard job but someone's got to do it
right but what keeps me going the fans
of course the fans if i do it for you
nothing makes me happier than passing on
my hamburger knowledge to you and
watching the flames
ignite within you that's why today's
episode is all about the fans it's the
fan appreciation episode right now any
minute now one lucky winner will show up
on set for my house
to make burgers with me let me tell you
the contest submissions were fantastic
they were amazing so much hard work went
into all these submissions let's take a
look
hi
hi
hi a little about me i like food moats
you and me let's make some burgers i
would absolutely love to be featured
because i am a huge freaking fan ah
smells like america
i love this passion that you've
instilled in me and i love being seen as
the burger guy in the neighborhood
today i'm going to show you some of the
tools you need to make a really great
burger flip
i did not mean to throw that
so
let's catch up here let's do this
i should wrap this up here's my
impression of george
i have the impossible task of having to
choose just one from the five entries we
had what what's that no i'm here no we
had over 500 entries the choice is very
difficult but it's time to meet the
winner
hello could you please welcome all the
way from charlotte north carolina
john cochran that is my name i'm here
how you doing i'm doing fantastic
journals how about yourself good to have
you so happy to have you here i feel
like i have willy wonka and you've won
the golden ticket hopefully i'm not
augustus gloop
you ever wonder what was behind the
cameras over there oh my gosh and now
you know nothing much right cabinetry
incredible what kicked off your
hamburger journey met my wife she is the
daughter of beef farmers
what yes so her family holy [ __ ] farm
yes so wait wait you you married into
ranching royalty yes wow we get monthly
shipments of ground beef from your
in-laws yes to the final amazing puzzle
piece was burger scholar sessions
because
i got to learn how to do this i want to
make sure that i do it the right way but
you've said many times on the show you
can do this yeah and you really owe it
to yourself out there to do it being
here as a fan is a big big deal i don't
take it lightly i wanted to bring some
goodies for you
from the fans uh to show our
appreciation for you okay
so some home grown favorites uh from
north carolina i know you have southern
roots so where are you
without oh dukes yes you cannot buy this
in new york look at this
deuce mayo thank you of course this is
awesome the fun continues my wife made
this now this is burger adjacent okay
okay
[Laughter]
meet your new pillow uh so she sewed
that john that's fantastic what's your
wife's name sarah thank you sarah this
is beautiful this is as beautiful as a
pillow can be but the most important
thing uh right in here uh your you said
the very first line on the show was it's
my job yes to
preserve hamburger history this here is
a shirt from a restaurant in uh
charlotte that is no more oh what the
place is bastard oh mr case okay yeah so
hamburger stands um i ate every tuesday
come on
two and a half wow
this your shirt it was he's giving me
his clothes yes see fans this is how
it's how it works fans thanks very much
thank you it's wonderful yeah it's very
important to know that you did not get
on this show because you have my shirt
and you have my spatula and you have my
underwear oh you don't mind where you
have my what else do you have some books
right it's not where you got the show
that's great thank you all right thank
you very much i thank you for obviously
buying all these things but
there's something you said in your
submission that actually
got us all going
you said that you have become like the
go-to guy in your neighborhood for all
things hamburger right that is true you
make burgers you answer burger questions
you've sort of like a mini you know
burger scholar of the neighborhood yeah
that's why you're here oh got the
griddle going miss crystal will walk her
dog down the street and she'll walk down
and say miss crystal come get a
hamburger and she'll walk over and i'll
just give her one i've uh i've
cooked at weddings at the birthday party
nothing gives me joy quite like seeing
somebody bite into a hamburger yeah it
was obvious it was palpable that you
were you were deeply immersed in hamburg
culture and that's why we had to have
you on the show we're gonna cook
obviously right you're here to cook okay
good but before we do that
now you need to answer a few trivia
questions oh we're gonna get you past a
quick trivia round here
but hey if you know the show and you're
as you say a big fan
you should be okay ready here we go okay
number one what is the air speed
velocity of a cheeseburger and laden
swallow
uh european or north africa
dude did you hear that did you [ __ ]
hear that
get specific come on holy [ __ ] do you
hear this
i'm shocked amazed that's amazing the
mississippi slug burger
where did it get its name uh it cost a
slug which is another name for a nickel
john's okay john's okay in my book
remember the time i almost skateboarded
into a vat of hot oil remember that
moment okay what did i shout out just
before the crash
[ __ ] watch out
[Music]
no
the answer we're looking for is hola
amigos
hola amigos
uh when shawn evans visited most burger
headquarters right here is still where
you're standing yes what did he put on
my burger all the last dab
[Music]
he's got it
nice work excellent
we can cook that let's go now we can
cook are you ready to make some burgers
let's do this
what's with the finger up because that's
what you said though yeah yeah
i know i did that jesus thank you thanks
john for pointing that out in your
submission you mentioned that the burger
you would like to see me make or make
with me
was the fried onion burger from oklahoma
i hear a friend of yours ask you to make
some of these burgers at their wedding
yes it's my job to make sure you're
going to go to this thing prepared first
you're going to make one
no pressure
i'm not going to judge i'm just going to
observe right
and then i'm going to make one i've been
25 000 in the last three years i've made
25. there you go
suddenly we've got all the elements of
the burger right in front of us right
then okay
first
how would you do this how would i do
this first i grabbed uh well i would
chop the onions up uh slice those
without chopping my finger off right uh
at that point i've used the scoop here
uh-huh
no
yeah you do a level not level scoop oh
it depends do we have so in the business
we have to level because we all know
they're the same size ah see i don't
want business so i do whatever i want
at that point
there you go then okay throw a dab of
salt on there okay oh it's okay there
you go yep uh i'm not judging oh i'm not
judging i'm just well i'm just just
watching observing just grab
that's right
there you go you use that many onions
usually more wow good okay
look at you
okay
and at that point we just wait so far so
good i'll tell you that much she's doing
okay
i'll take okay you know when to flip
right yeah you can hear it but more
importantly you can see that all that
liquid pop up at the top and if you see
uh crust forming around the edges
exactly that's what you want when you
cook it up man burgers that uh what
about these what should the onions be
doing they should uh smell great
they do
[Laughter]
how are we doing
you happy with it don't burn your face
we wouldn't be losing a lot if i burned
my face
um
oh yeah you should scraper there you go
yeah
smells good what what are we doing next
oh must
and then what happens
here we throw our bun on top to let it
ride that way the uh the onion
and beef look at it
so pretty much you've done everything
the way i would do it except one thing
you haven't done yet which i'll explain
when i make mine interesting yeah but
you're done pretty good here that
doesn't matter two another i'm actually
thinking of two or three or four things
yeah four yes four i think sorry oh
but have i still passed the test i
haven't had the burger yet oh
well of course you would eat of course
yeah
okay how do you know when you're done
there
uh when my wife says please bring in the
hamburger we need to eat dinner
so look at him there he goes okay
excellent john i think you're doing a
fantastic job oh george
there you go three look at you
in a little rose pattern do i get to
taste this now of course
looks good this is pretty accurate
oh hey mmm a little salty it was good
yeah
[Music]
hmm john
that is good john
and see this is why i do it because
somebody else gets to enjoy it hang on
not perfect oh
good
okay good
step on that
super hot
okay
john
you've done a great job but i'm gonna
show you
a few tips i bring them on
that i do to make it even better let's
do it one thing you notice how you when
you pulled away the audience came with
you yeah you don't want that i'm going
to show you what happens when you cook
them a little more you'll see
some tricks here we go ready switch
let's switch if you're dealing with a
lot of burgers you're going to want a
portion for sure you end up with a level
scoop see that look at that see
perfectly level see that now we know
it's exactly what it should be with
having that now you have a flat surface
so it's not a ball it's a half a ball
you had the onions right absolutely
right right
yeah the idea is perfect but to follow
around the sides a little bit see that
yes
because what's going to happen is you're
going to have onions cooked in
in three different stages almost burnt
caramelized and then just softened yeah
this is the most important part okay you
look at the ball okay you don't want to
go straight down
you're never going to get lazy edges if
you go straight down you're going to
want to actually go off to one side so i
actually it's a little bit off to one
side right i push back
and i push forward and i watch it come
on the other side right i got a glacier
see that same thing on this side
i'm ready to flip here so right
collect the onions a little bit right
over we go
there you go
cheese on there right away right we let
it ride right
sorry thanks buddy
okay now here's something that i do all
the time now which is i actually
manipulate see i just did there
because quick it happens quick but i
actually tuck all the onions in now aha
there's a reason why they'll burn if
they're hanging out by themselves on the
outside yeah they won't burn it through
underneath
and then you could also by the way do
this ready check it oh [ __ ]
see looks pretty good pretty close
almost there so here you go mind is
blown there there are brain chunks all
over george's uh house okay it makes so
much sense now
yeah old school hamburger choice that
was to take the bottom butt off put it
underneath
the spatula and do what's called a pinch
and pull pinch and pull there you go a
little pinching pull for you buddy
people are going to want to have this
burger wrapped up there you go
well
had i known i was going to come up here
and get shown
i might have better prepared but i get
to eat so
it's a small price to pay so uh yeah i i
don't want to wait to chew into this
let's do it
i mean what what can i say that hasn't
already been said but it's similar to
yours right yeah yeah pretty cool
particularly
we're on the same highway
i'm not in the the hov lane yeah
incredible incredible i mean you know i
see pictures of this i've seen videos of
this and i said bye i don't turn out
this way what is what is happening this
was the perfect this is everything that
i was hoping for
i i appreciate it it's a true honor and
hopefully i represented all the fans
well and you know it's i get to pass
down my griddle
spatula to my uh daughter when she grows
up so it's we are creating history here
together awesome john thank you thank
you
michelle toast
thanks everybody we'll see you on the
next season of burger scholar sessions
thanks to john right it's good to have a
fan in the kitchen yeah and he really is
like this in real
there's no life right
[Music]
hey thanks for watching burger scholar
sessions you should like and subscribe
to this channel but also get more
episodes up here
somewhere in here right there
yeah watch more episodes right here